girl congratulations you are right this
is your night oh my god we made it i
realized after this many years we never
got to celebrate in person so it's the
first time you've got quite a bit of
time to make up tonight so how are we
gonna celebrate this looks incredible
i'm just so excited to see the cast my
family my friends are here it's very
it makes me feel really good well
something else that might make you feel
very good is that there's already awards
season buzz for season two i mean what
does that mean to you look i can't
believe we got to even make a season one
and then got away with it and then got
to make a season two and i'm just
excited to celebrate everybody tonight
and what we did it's a bigger season so
there's a lot involved a lot of hands
that made the magic and i'm glad
everyone gets to experience that tonight
it means you got to keep the plane in
the air and keep going
calm down you might have to come in for
a landing at some point we can't fly
forever a quick layover
back in the air the layover would be
nice a layover could be very good yes
well i am so happy for you can you
believe this year marks 30 years since
your first acting credit
30 years that's crazy yes that is wild
oh my god i've been doing this way too
long
thank you i still don't know how to get
the the hair out of my lipstick though
that's that's taken me 30 years
what do you what would you tell your
younger self beginning in those years
about where your acting career would
would leacha oh my god i guess keep
going and you're going to be on et one
day baby here we are
keep on going don't stop so tomorrow
we're actually going to be with mayam
celebrating her directorial debut can
you send her a congratulatory message
yes congrats mayam the film looks
fantastic i can't wait to see it i'm so
happy for you
speaking of films really quick that we
can't wait to see meet cute with pete
davidson how much fun did you two have
it's cute the movie is so cute he's cute
we had so much fun he's hilarious i i
don't know how they're going to edit it
together because all we did was laugh
um and screw up our lines um but it was
a it's an adorable movie i'm very proud
of it and now he's out here in love how
happy are you for him i am so happy for
him he deserves it he's a total
sweetheart so it's great